china y eeuu parecen haber dejado de
lado su rivalidad histórica y haber
empezado a colaborar en la lucha
climática esto lo hacen a través de un
comunicado conjunto basado en otro
comunicado a otro anuncio que hicieron
en abril de este año en el que se
comprometen a acelerar la acción
climática durante esta década un anuncio
a destacar el de china que dijo que
desarrollará un plan nacional y
exhaustivo para reducir sus emisiones de
metano el año que viene esto recordemos
es importante porque china no formaba
parte de los países que habían anunciado
durante la primera semana de la cumbre
un plan para reducir un 30% sus
emisiones de metano antes del 2030
kerry además recordó que reducir este
gas de efecto invernadero es una manera
rápida de limitar el aumento de las
temperaturas en el mundo es decir es una
acción a corto plazo ambos dijeron que
los dos países se habían reunido más de
30 veces para lograr un consenso y kerry
afirmó que cada paso cuenta tras la
visita de boris johnson a las
instalaciones de la cope durante el día
de hoy este mensaje se recibe aquí en
glasgow como un empujón para acelerar
las negociaciones y que los países se
pongan de acuerdo para lograr un texto
común que se apruebe a finales de esta
semana y que sea efectivo en la lucha
contra el cambio climático